starting as early as 2007 currency
traders at several multinational banks
formed a group that they dubbed the
cartel it's perhaps fitting that they
chose that name as it aptly describes
the brazenly illegal behavior that they
were engaged in on a mere five year
basis almost every day for more than
five years traders in this cartel used a
private electronic chatroom to
manipulate the spot markets exchange
rate between euros and dollars using
coded language to conceal their
collusion they acted as partners rather
than competitors in an effort to push
the exchange rate in directions
favorable to their banks but detrimental
to many others now the prices the market
sets for those currencies influence
virtually every sector of every economy
in the world their actions inflated the
bank's profits while harming countless
consumers investors and institutions
around the globe from pension funds to
major corporations and including the
bank's own customers who placed their
faith in the market and relied on it to
produce a competitive exchange rate as a
result of our investigation four of the
world's largest banks have agreed to
plead guilty to felony antitrust
violations they are citicorp jpmorgan
chase & Company Barclays Plc and the
royal bank of scotland plc these four
banks have acknowledged their role in
this conspiracy and committed to
changing their corporate cultures
starting at the highest levels they've
also agreed to pay criminal fines
totaling more than 2.5 billion dollars
the largest set of antitrust finds ever
obtained in the history of the
Department of Justice and the find that
citicorp alone will pay 925 million
dollars is the largest single fine ever
imposed for a violation of the Sherman
Act these unprecedented figures
appropriately reflect the conspiracies
breathtaking flagrancy it's systemic
reach and its significance
and impact a fifth bank Switzerland's
UBS AG has agreed to plead guilty and
pay a 203 million dollar criminal
penalty for breaching the
non-prosecution agreement it entered in
December 2012 regarding manipulation of
the London interbank offered rate or
LIBOR a benchmark interest rate used
worldwide the breach of this
non-prosecution agreement was based in
part on UBS as fraudulent and deceptive
currency trading and sales practices
related to the foreign exchange markets
and its collusion with other
participants in the FX markets and its
failure to take adequate action to
prevent unlawful conduct after prior
civil criminal and regulatory
resolutions in other words UBS promised
in other resolutions not to commit
additional crimes but it did